Julie Stout: Okay, we are recording. Hello, my name is Julie Stout, today is March 23rd, 2026, and I'm here with Richard Fredoutis, and I am located in Bloomington, Indiana, and can you remind me where you are located, Richard?
Richard Vidutis: Hi, this is Richard the Dudis, and I'm in Alexandria, Virginia.
Julie Stout: Great.
Julie Stout: We are here for part two of our oral history interviews with Richard here, and we are going to dive right into the Dawson Gary project, and also comments on Dawson himself, if you are good to go.
Richard Vidutis: Okay, good.
Julie Stout: Awesome
Julie Stout: So, my first question for you is, related to the Gary Project. What is your first involvement with this project, and how did you become connected to it?
Richard Vidutis: I had, spent a year in, in, as an exchange student in Poland.
Richard Vidutis: And then, for some reason, I can't remember exactly, I didn't start in grad school, That fall, but…
Richard Vidutis: I guess in January, and I think the Gary project had already started.
Richard Vidutis: So I came in… Late… And I… and I never got a spot to do actual,
Richard Vidutis: searching for informants, I just kind of helped out.
Richard Vidutis: A lot of people with the, videoing.
Richard Vidutis: And interviewing with people.
Julie Stout: What was your experience with the, equipment itself before you jumped on board to this project?
Richard Vidutis: But one of the things, apparently they got a… I'm really,
Richard Vidutis: Big sum of money, and
Richard Vidutis: One of the things they wanted to do was get the latest tech equipment.
Richard Vidutis: That… back then, that meant… A video recorder that was only black and white.
Richard Vidutis: And the machine weighed, I think, about 20 pounds, or something like that.
Richard Vidutis: And you have to wear it on your back as a backpack.
Richard Vidutis: Plus, there was a cable with the, actual, you know, the camera, the lens.
Richard Vidutis: So sometimes we walk it… we would work in pairs. Somebody would, hold, you know, have the backpack on, and the other person would…
Richard Vidutis: Film and the interview.
Richard Vidutis: Of course, it's possible… it was possible to do that.
Richard Vidutis: By one person.
Richard Vidutis: But when you compare it today, our smartphones produce better video than that did back then.
Richard Vidutis: So anyway, we were very excited about getting that video. Thought it was the latest thing, so…
Richard Vidutis: And they were open and real.
Richard Vidutis: Open, real searches.
Richard Vidutis: really ancient now.
Julie Stout: Did you work with this equipment, previously, like, in Poland as an exchange student, or what was.
Richard Vidutis: It was all living, everybody.
Julie Stout: Oh!
Julie Stout: But they just wanted more support for the, specifically the equipment and everything.
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, I think somebody said, you know, not just to interview somebody on tape, but actually film them while we were doing it, filming the events that took place,
Richard Vidutis: Whatever they were. Which was a great idea, of course.
Richard Vidutis: That's the way you should do it.
Julie Stout: Which of the Gary Gang students did you work with the most, or did you work with all of them?
Richard Vidutis: I think I just worked with Richard March and Elena Bredunas. I may have…
Richard Vidutis: Maybe on occasion, but it would have been very rare, and I don't remember clearly.
Richard Vidutis: Dawson may have been there a few times. We actually, did go out to Milan Volpacic.
Richard Vidutis: Dawson writes about him.
Richard Vidutis: in his book.
Richard Vidutis: And he was, he made instruments for the, Croatians and the Serbs, something like the Vandura, for example.
Richard Vidutis: So we went out there to film that.
Richard Vidutis: Altogether March Dorsen and I.
Richard Vidutis: But with Elena's, we… Went out to document this lady who did Easter eggs.
Richard Vidutis: We found her.
Richard Vidutis: And I may have filmed some other stuff, there was a…
Richard Vidutis: a Macedonian hall not far from my parents' house, where we also filmed they're dancing.
Richard Vidutis: Those are the things that I remember. There may have been more, but it's been a very long time.
Julie Stout: What was it like to come back to Gary for specifically this project?
Richard Vidutis: Well, it was really crazy. I mean, I grew up there without…
Richard Vidutis: There's this project that's gonna open up the whole city in terms of What it consists of?
Richard Vidutis: I never thought of
Richard Vidutis: doing that in any way whatsoever, so it was really fascinating to see the different aspects and layers of the city that we were…
Richard Vidutis: Getting into interviewing all kinds of people.
Richard Vidutis: various traditions that I never knew existed, and I would never have known, because, you know, people kind of live on their own shelves, and they never pursue things like that, especially traditions. You may have come across them occasionally, but…
Richard Vidutis: Never in this depth.
Julie Stout: You mentioned, milan… QCube, can you say that name again for me?
Richard Vidutis: Popachic. Popacic.
Julie Stout: Was that a memorable experience for you to record and interact with? And if so, like, are there other ones?
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, later as I, did more projects,
Richard Vidutis: I started thinking about some of the theories of folklore.
Richard Vidutis: taught me when I started, and some of those are very romanticized,
Richard Vidutis: They tend to split society into some sort of pre-industrial folk, and then the modern world.
Richard Vidutis: And in these two occasions, I realized, years later, like, the, Easter egg maker and Milan making the instruments.
Richard Vidutis: These people were totally mechanized. They were modern-day people. They were not…
Richard Vidutis: some kind of pre-industrial. They were creating traditional
Richard Vidutis: Very old artifacts, you know, that date back
Richard Vidutis: I don't know how far the Bandura goes back, or the Easter eggs go back.
Richard Vidutis: But they were using modern-day mechanized methods, and so…
Richard Vidutis: Occasionally, a folklorists will discuss that.
Richard Vidutis: But to me, it was like,
Richard Vidutis: I was being told that there was this pre-industrial people out there.
Richard Vidutis: In fact, one of the things that anybody who makes anything, they will always use the fastest and most efficient tool they can get ahold of.
Richard Vidutis: So it kind of questions sometimes some of the courses that you get, at least that I got back then.
Julie Stout: Doing this work, did it change your perspective on what you thought going into the project versus what you actually were able to document?
Richard Vidutis: I really didn't have anything to… to expect from this. I'd never done fieldwork before, I'd never gotten involved deeply with communities.
Richard Vidutis: you know, asking deep questions of what they do. To me, it was all totally new. I mean, I was just an open…
Richard Vidutis: Both in book.
Richard Vidutis: Just write whatever you can in it.
Richard Vidutis: So, it was just a learning experience. It's only years later that I, you know, started thinking about it and analyzing it.
Richard Vidutis: I was just stoked.
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, I love photography, so that's…
Richard Vidutis: I love doing that, and that,
Richard Vidutis: But theoretically, it was years later that I… Try to understand what happened.
Julie Stout: What lessons did you learn from conducting this fieldwork that you took into your career and contract work later on?
Richard Vidutis: Well, field work and what that entails,
Richard Vidutis: You need to do some research about the communities that you're going into.
Richard Vidutis: You need to find people who can help you discover other people and other events taking place.
Richard Vidutis: You just go for how good you are at dealing with people?
Richard Vidutis: I'm basically a shy person, but…
Richard Vidutis: You have to learn how to approach people, and… Especially…
Richard Vidutis: To keep any kind of bias, if possible, out of your interactions with somebody else.
Richard Vidutis: And then, Gary, one of the big elements was racism.
Richard Vidutis: And that's one of the things that I found Actually alarmed me.
Richard Vidutis: I have no actual, you know, hatred towards anybody, but…
Richard Vidutis: When we started going out into the field.
Richard Vidutis: this kind of crazy fear, you know, like, oh my god, we're going into a plaque area, whatever that means. I have no idea, except that
Richard Vidutis: It's the shared fear.
Richard Vidutis: That society sometimes instills in you.
Richard Vidutis: And that was a really big, instrument to break that kind of… So…
Richard Vidutis: you know, closed-off world that I was… I discovered I was in, so… It was very instrumental.
Julie Stout: Because you grew up in the area previously, why…
Julie Stout: how do I… how do I ask this? You mentioned having to break that notion of, like, oh my gosh, I'm going…
Julie Stout: Of, like, a certain type of people that I have been told things about.
Julie Stout: Why did you think you still had to break that, even though you grew up in the area already? I know you touched on this a little bit in our first interview, because, you mentioned having people of different ethnicities who were your friends already, but I'm just curious about that.
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, I don't know. I mean, when it happens, you see yourself, and the question is, wait a minute, why am I reacting this way?
Richard Vidutis: Even though, you know, most of my friends, like the Mexicans, were dark.
Richard Vidutis: When Cuevas was Black, he was a Puerto Rican.
Richard Vidutis: I don't know, I don't know how that works. Maybe it's really cultural and not… not racial. It's how people behave.
Richard Vidutis: Maybe that's the fear we have.
Richard Vidutis: Because when I was a little kid in grade school.
Richard Vidutis: I don't know how old I must have been, 7 or 8.
Richard Vidutis: There was something that happened, and a grown man slugged me. He really hardened me.
Richard Vidutis: You damaged my ear, chunk.
Richard Vidutis: And he was black.
Richard Vidutis: And John Cuevas from Puerto Rico, who's also Black, Started chasing him.
Richard Vidutis: And yelling, I'm gonna kill you, nigga.
Richard Vidutis: And there's a little kid.
Richard Vidutis: what's going on here? Are there two black people acting like that? Like, what's the difference, you know?
Richard Vidutis: Apparently, it's behavior. I can't go too deep into this because it's so complicated, but
Richard Vidutis: I just learned a lot from that, even though later I was still harboring some kind of fears, you know, going into different communities.
Richard Vidutis: I think you'll always have that, even though when I was doing my dissertation up in the Michigan
Richard Vidutis: And, the fins, because they're all white.
Richard Vidutis: I also had that fear of, like, I'm going into the, I don't know what I'm gonna meet, what's gonna happen.
Richard Vidutis: I think you always have that kind of fear.
Richard Vidutis: But those incidents in my childhood were really instrumental, even In early, college,
Richard Vidutis: And breaking a lot of those stereotypes that I found I had.
Richard Vidutis: I don't know, we can go deeper into this, but it gets kind of complicated. It's kind of interesting to…
Julie Stout: It, the question was a spur-of-the-moment one, and I know it's not easy to answer, so thank you for trying your best to answer it. It's something that…
Julie Stout: like you said, I think it's ingrained in us, it's socialized into us, there's a lot of different things that can affect that, I think.
Julie Stout: But
Julie Stout: I know that you mentioned that this is your first fieldwork experience, and that was instrumental in helping you
Julie Stout: Learn what fieldwork was, to then do fieldwork later on in your different… in your career and your work, correct?
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, it was a door that opened up.
Julie Stout: Yeah, the door opened up for you.
Julie Stout: Which leads me into my next question, which is…
Julie Stout: When you were brought into the project, do you…
Julie Stout: Know what were the project aims at the start, and how did they evolve, or how did your role evolve through the project, if at all?
Richard Vidutis: It didn't really evolve, and I was never…
Richard Vidutis: Part of any kind of, group meetings, even, to discuss, you know, how it's going.
Richard Vidutis: But the further angles it would be.
Richard Vidutis: It was basically kind of following other people and helping them out.
Richard Vidutis: So we never got real… I don't know, I think that's probably a good intake question.
Richard Vidutis: How the project evolved.
Richard Vidutis: I would be really fascinated to learn how it did, and how it… started.
Julie Stout: It's interesting, because I asked her that question, and she told me that the students would have a better time answering that question. And so she didn't really dive super far into that, but,
Julie Stout: She definitely dealt with the administrative stuff on the back end, the logistics and everything, but it's truly Dawson would be the best person to answer this, but sadly, he is no longer with us.
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, and Dawson was, kind of a strict person. I'm sure he had really strong ideas.
Richard Vidutis: He would tell people, basically, what to do,
Richard Vidutis: Exactly, yeah. He was the person that I avoided, because he was so strict all the time. I only took one course with him.
Richard Vidutis: No, I don't remember what it was.
Richard Vidutis: But he was also, of course, he was… he published 20 books, and he was a really good writer.
Richard Vidutis: He's also a great editor. I mean, I brought up some projects I was writing, and he…
Richard Vidutis: First thing he does, takes out a red pen and marks out all the typos and everything. It scares the crap out of me. Oh, no.
Richard Vidutis: Okay, Dawson, I'm gonna stay away from you.
Julie Stout: That's… that's fair, that's fair.
Julie Stout: And I'm excited to ask you more questions about Dawson in our next section. Continuing on with this, the Gary project.
Julie Stout: You mentioned working with the woman who was carving Easter eggs, the Lithuanian woman, and then Milano… Milan Obernitch?
Richard Vidutis: What could you?
Julie Stout: Thank you. Opichitch. Thank you. Did you have other key people or groups that you remember or worked with, and what, and what did each contribute to the project?
Richard Vidutis: No, I don't have that kind of, experience, so…
Julie Stout: No worries.
Julie Stout: Because I, the videos that you mentioned and recorded are still in the archive today, and so they are included in my project as well, as I showed you a bit last time. And so there's an impact there, still, as well.
Julie Stout: My next question is…
Julie Stout: related to any stories or anecdotes that you may have had. What are moments that best captured the project spirit, or what stood out to you, in terms of…
Julie Stout: A success, or maybe challenges that you faced?
Richard Vidutis: Well, I was impressed that he tried to really cover
Richard Vidutis: that vast area from South Chicago all the way east of Gary, where, midwest and Bethlehem still.
Richard Vidutis: Put up new plants, so that's like…
Richard Vidutis: I don't know, what is that, 50 miles or so of industrial… Landscape…
Richard Vidutis: And when you… I looked at his book again, I haven't looked at it for years.
Richard Vidutis: He does a really good job at presenting not just,
Richard Vidutis: The history of these places, but also the sort of the,
Richard Vidutis: The way he describes those, sort of the present-day ethnography of these areas, before he goes into
Richard Vidutis: Out of those interviews that he published.
Richard Vidutis: So… He had a really thorough understanding of it, and he took us with him, you know?
Richard Vidutis: Boom.
Richard Vidutis: We were all over the place, I mean, like, Richard March and I, one time, when you crossed the, Illinois border into Indiana.
Richard Vidutis: There is a wolf Lake, I don't assigned, I'm just…
Richard Vidutis: I don't think I was dreaming it, but it was there.
Richard Vidutis: It said, dumping of radioactive material Prohibited without license.
Richard Vidutis: That can't be true, but I'm sure it was… it said that. So this thing was, like, so polluted, and yet there were people fishing there.
Richard Vidutis: So Richard and I went out there to interview people, we tried to interview them.
Richard Vidutis: And we were getting nervous, because…
Richard Vidutis: Some guys are looking at us and at our equipment and stuff, so…
Richard Vidutis: But it was areas like that. We tried everything, you know, that…
Richard Vidutis: We could. We had that freehand to do it.
Richard Vidutis: But Dawson also had his ideas, and that directed us, primarily, but we opened up a lot of that for him, because we just went everywhere.
Richard Vidutis: So, that was a great experience, you know, if you're doing field work, if you're a field worker.
Richard Vidutis: for somebody new in the field, if you didn't have that opportunity.
Richard Vidutis: slowly, you would work your way into doing fieldwork, but this thing was just, it was a team effort. That's the other thing that really impressed me.
Richard Vidutis: That's something that I took with me. I always thought that all the other…
Richard Vidutis: Folklore project could be teamwork, and that's just not true, unfortunately.
Richard Vidutis: But it was… that was one of the great hallmarks of the project teamwork.
Julie Stout: Are there any other key artifacts or materials that you want to highlight that you were able to record or interact with?
Richard Vidutis: Can't really think of… I just remembered a…
Richard Vidutis: the previous question, you asked about anecdotes in this.
Richard Vidutis: Comes from my own dissertation.
Richard Vidutis: in the Upper Peninsula, but it's about Dorsen.
Richard Vidutis: Dorsal had this really interesting laugh.
Richard Vidutis: And I often thought of him and Jerry Lewis, who was a comedian from way back then.
Richard Vidutis: And that same kind of… nervous… Laugh. So…
Richard Vidutis: When I was doing my dissertation fieldwork up here in Michigan, I also did a project for,
Richard Vidutis: on the museum at Michigan State University in East Lansing when I was interviewing, Ojibbalo.
Richard Vidutis: people in the community there. It's a big community up there.
Richard Vidutis: And I was talking to this one lady, Mrs. Welsh, her husband had
Richard Vidutis: was really famous, he had died, but he was, sort of like the Indian icon for Michigan, and…
Richard Vidutis: She brought out all of these deerskin clothes that he wore, and all the beadwork on it and everything, and she's explaining this, and then all of a sudden, she says.
Richard Vidutis: And, you know, there's… and she's really old.
Richard Vidutis: I say aye. And she's really old, and she says, you know, There's somebody else around here.
Richard Vidutis: I don't know.
Richard Vidutis: Moving through the woods, asking people stuff.
Richard Vidutis: And he had this really weird laugh.
Richard Vidutis: And then, you know, he sent me a book. It was, like, Bears something?
Richard Vidutis: I got it.
Richard Vidutis: She was talking about doors, and SAT was still there 40 years ago.
Richard Vidutis: Previous to me.
Richard Vidutis: But it was that laugh when she said, that weird laugh, and it was starting so…
Richard Vidutis: almost starting to think of Dorsen, and then she says, That book title.
Richard Vidutis: Anyway, so that's my one anecdote that doesn't go from the Gary Project, but it is about his
Richard Vidutis: That laughs that everybody sort of remembers.
Julie Stout: The fact that it was so memorable that it still stood out to her.
Julie Stout: Even after time has passed is amazing.
Richard Vidutis: Well, that happens to a lot of old folks. They seem to remember things that happened way back in
Richard Vidutis: Almost their teams, yeah, that's kind of common.
Julie Stout: I want to dive into the challenges that you faced on the project. I know, the other students that I interviewed and talked to talked about the challenges specifically with the equipment, and so this is a…
Julie Stout: Question to you, both about the equipment, but also, can you think of any other challenges that you encountered on the project, and how were they addressed?
Richard Vidutis: Oh… I really can't. I mean, I don't… I can't think of anything really Negative?
Richard Vidutis: The equipment I didn't think was a problem, but maybe, you know, some people don't like technical stuff, so they found it a problem.
Richard Vidutis: But, yeah, sorry, I just can't think of anything. To me, it was just always exciting.
Richard Vidutis: Just all this discovery of my… Community.
Richard Vidutis: there was this Albanian… I mean, this, Macedonian hall to the left of my parents' house, and…
Richard Vidutis: To the other was, a Polish hall, which I never knew existed.
Richard Vidutis: And these… We're all over the city, man, it was really amazing.
Richard Vidutis: I was going through the doors of the book, and one of the things said.
Richard Vidutis: I was wondering why he didn't put more emphasis into it was, the parish, churches, and schools
Richard Vidutis: it doesn't really go into that at all, and I don't know, it's… Because he's uncomfortable with…
Richard Vidutis: different language speakers, I don't know what the problem was.
Richard Vidutis: But those are really important.
Richard Vidutis: I lived… I think I mentioned last time I lived this…
Richard Vidutis: Closer to St. Hemricks of Slovak.
Richard Vidutis: Could have gone out to a Slovak school.
Richard Vidutis: But they were all over the place, all of them.
Richard Vidutis: And he really doesn't… I don't know why he didn't cover that. And also, the other…
Richard Vidutis: other topic he didn't mention much is the, trying to maintain the culture. It's not just
Richard Vidutis: To put on events and displays.
Richard Vidutis: He's a folklorist, he's looking for expressive… Moments.
Richard Vidutis: What?
Richard Vidutis: A lot of this, a lot of these groups are trying to maintain their culture
Richard Vidutis: In a foreign land, And those are really important moments, too. They were in the Lithuanian parish.
Richard Vidutis: But he doesn't talk about that stuff, though.
Richard Vidutis: I'm just trying to think of something, really, that was hard. I don't know, to me, it was just this excitement, not stop.
Richard Vidutis: Both.
Richard Vidutis: I don't know what else to say, so…
Julie Stout: That's totally fine, this is all your own perspective, and so don't feel forced to say anything that you don't want to, or, go into things that you think weren't applicable to your experience.
Julie Stout: I want to ask you two more questions, and so my first one for you is about impact, legacy, and your own reflection on it. You dove into a little bit of your reflection on it.
Julie Stout: But what lasting impacts stand out to you for the participants, for IU, for yourself, and maybe even the field? What stands out to you?
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, I was thinking about it a little bit. I think this project…
Richard Vidutis: Can be seen in a wider scope.
Richard Vidutis: Back in 1977, a TV program called Roots appeared.
Richard Vidutis: And it was extremely popular. It was about… A black…
Richard Vidutis: Slave History was, I think it was the ABC that put it on.
Richard Vidutis: It had such a great impact.
Richard Vidutis: Across the country. It wasn't just for blacks. I was in, Detroit and Wayne at that time.
Richard Vidutis: And, It was so powerful that even… The local archives, or…
Richard Vidutis: Just almost overrun by polls, but also searching for their histories, which was not apparently that big of a deal.
Richard Vidutis: So, this is part of a wider Kind of out of, rebirth of interest in ethnicity.
Richard Vidutis: Even to the point where,
Richard Vidutis: ethnic jokes back then. Oh my god, like, everybody was collecting ethnic jokes. I was up in Michigan.
Richard Vidutis: talking to several people, and they…
Richard Vidutis: They had Dakota jokes they were telling me.
Richard Vidutis: And everybody had them, and some of those, you know, were…
Richard Vidutis: The… they were slurs, but it was just going on seriously.
Richard Vidutis: And this whole thing of ethnicity, it just bloomed that America was the ethnic, almost, empire in the world, contrast to what's going on today.
Richard Vidutis: So that was really cool, and they're just… a lot of…
Richard Vidutis: Dissertations and studies going on about ethnicity.
Richard Vidutis: Not just flats, but all kinds of people, worker class.
Richard Vidutis: That was the heyday.
Richard Vidutis: And no longer. I mean, it's very different today. So, I was part of that, and that was… it was really fascinating.
Julie Stout: If you could… if you could go back and change
Julie Stout: anything about the way you participated in the project, or what are some things you maybe wish I've known… you wish you had known before the project and your work? What would those be?
Richard Vidutis: Oh… I don't know. Like I say, it was the first time I really did.
Richard Vidutis: extensive fieldwork, so I wasn't sure what fieldwork even meant, or what it… entails,
Richard Vidutis: I think maybe one of the… Lost elements was, multilingualism.
Richard Vidutis: that existed. It was not covered by Dorsum. Even when he talks about folklore of steel.
Richard Vidutis: He kind of parallels it with the other work that he did with
Richard Vidutis: I don't know, minors or something in it.
Richard Vidutis: how they used to sing at their jobs and all this. I mean, that doesn't happen in the steel mills. And what happened in the steel mills was that there were so many different ethnic groups
Richard Vidutis: My father, we used to talk about that. He said, geez, you know, There's Poles, Ukrainians, Russians.
Richard Vidutis: And we kind of developed almost, like, a unique language to speak of some kind of syllabic God knows what.
Richard Vidutis: That made it work.
Richard Vidutis: Huh?
Richard Vidutis: But, again, the small legalism endorsing doesn't deal with that at all.
Julie Stout: I asked that question because you mentioned a bit in our first interview and a bit in this one what you wish Dawson would have touched on in the work.
Julie Stout: Is there anything else you'd like to add that you feel like you may have missed, or…
Julie Stout: could have done better, I guess.
Richard Vidutis: No, except for what I just said, but as a folklorist, I think you did a great job.
Richard Vidutis: I don't know how many hours of the interpret,
Richard Vidutis: of interviews were done, because I remember in the office.
Richard Vidutis: There was always at least one or two people constantly transcribing and transcribing all this stuff.
Richard Vidutis: And it's in the book.
Richard Vidutis: But again, he said it was a 500-page manuscript, and this book is only around 200, I think.
Richard Vidutis: So it just leads me wondering what else. Maybe it's the formatting? They…
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, small script, and 200 is actually 5. I don't know.
Richard Vidutis: But, I think… I think he made some kind of comment, like, they kept some stuff out.
Richard Vidutis: They wanted to be more popular than scholarly.
Richard Vidutis: Yeah, I guess that's true, when you look… okay, kind of highlights the… the… -
Richard Vidutis: crime, and racism, whatever else. That's kind of…
Richard Vidutis: Popular, I guess, I don't know.
Richard Vidutis: But the scholarly part, I think, maybe… Maybe missing from that sugar.
Julie Stout: Yeah, that's fair.
Julie Stout: I know that there's some notes on his manuscript work in the archive, but there isn't a full manuscript that I'm aware of.
Julie Stout: Of his, book that he ended up publishing for it.
Julie Stout: But…
Richard Vidutis: Yes.
Julie Stout: Yeah, but would you like to add anything else about the Gary project, your involvement in it, your perspective, your takeaways, whatever you want to discuss?
Richard Vidutis: I don't know, I think that's pretty much it, I mean, I was just so…
Richard Vidutis: I was surprised that there's a project being done.
Richard Vidutis: About Gary.
Richard Vidutis: Like, initially, like, who the hell would want to study theory?
Richard Vidutis: Everybody wants to leave.
Richard Vidutis: But… No, all of these places are always jam-packed with unbelievable data.
Richard Vidutis: He tried to get to it.
Richard Vidutis: But from a folkloric perspective, Though I think he did.
Richard Vidutis: Include… a lot of ethnographic background, which is… I always think is important, needs to be done.
Richard Vidutis: people, I think, avoided him at,
Richard Vidutis: At the university, because he taught courses that were basically history. History of folklore and that sort of stuff.
Richard Vidutis: There's a lot of people didn't find it exciting.
Richard Vidutis: And I tried reading, some book reviews, and the same stuff comes up that is too historical.
Richard Vidutis: Somebody had to do it, he did it.
Julie Stout: That's very true.
Julie Stout: Well, that was my last question for this section, so I'm going to stop the recording here.